let's take a trip back to 2013 when
Democrats actually supported what they
now oppose on March 7th of that year the
Senate had confirmed Obama CIA director
nominee John Brennan now bear in mind he
was previously director of the National
Counterterrorism Center and reportedly a
supporter of enhanced interrogation 13
Republicans were among the 63 senators
who voted to confirm Brennan including
senators Lindsey Graham and John McCain
just two Democrats voted against the
nominee Pat Leahy and Jeff Merkley along
with independent Bernie Sanders now the
issue of Brennan's involvement in
enhanced interrogation that whole
program didn't concern the Democrats on
the Senate Intel committee back then of
the 50 Democrats who voted to confirm
Brennan in 2013 36 are still in office
during Brennan's confirmation hearing in
February of 2013 weaponized drones with
a big issue this is how the question of
waterboarding was addressed what steps
did you take to stop CA from moving to
these techniques you now say you found
objectionable at the time I did not take
steps to stop the CIA's use of those
techniques I was not in the chain of
command of that program I had expressed
my personal objections and views to my
some agency colleagues about a certain
of those AIT such as waterboarding
nudity and others where I professed my
personal objections to it but I did not
try to stop it because it was you know
something that was being done and in a
different part of the agency under the
authority of others and it was something
that was directed by the administration
at the time and that was that move on
well it wasn't until December of 2014
when the Senate Intel committee released
a report severely criticizing enhanced
interrogation describing the techniques
as torture which yielded little
intelligence that anyone began to really
care that much about it during a press
conference at CIA director Brennan
suddenly reverse course defended the
program and
used to label techniques like
waterboarding torture even the media
seemed a little bit sympathetic NBC's
Andrea Mitchell she loved this softball
at the CIA director do you think the bin
Laden case can be attributed in some
part to enhanced interrogation
techniques or torture the detainees who
were subjected to enhanced interrogation
techniques provided information that was
useful and was used in the ultimate
operation to go against bin Laden well
not only did he go on the record
defending the Bush administration's
aggressive interrogation tactics he also
reportedly objected to the Obama
administration's decision to release the
Bush interrogation memos and other
related documents apparently he did
think the program had value whether or
not it actually led to the elimination
of bin Laden you know who knows but now
remember Brennan was the CIA's deputy
executive director when enhanced
interrogation techniques were being used
and he still was confirmed as CIA
director by Democrats Brennan was also
the superior to Gina Haspel now
president Trump's nominee to become CIA
director were you involved in any way in
the creation of the enhanced
interrogation program senator I was not
and I was not read into the program
until about a year into its existence
and guess who learned about the enhanced
interrogation at about the same time as
Gina Haskell Congress yes fast forward
to today and suddenly Nancy Pelosi and
her fellow Democrats want to raise a big
fuss and pretend that they hold the
moral high ground against torture where
were her objections or any of their
objections when they were being briefed
on these techniques instead Democrats
and Republicans like McCain and Paul are
using the has you know hospital's
involvement in the program to try to
block her confirmation a CIA director
boy what a difference four years makes
mr. Brennan is without a doubt qualified
for this position people who have worked
closely with him regularly cite his work
ethic his integrity and his
determination John Brennan by all
accounts will be a strong leader while
many nominees have classified
backgrounds you are very unique or are
you an advocate for destroying the tapes
it's been legal a tear of what those
tapes contained did you oversee the
enhanced interrogation of Alma shiri
which included the use of the waterboard
as publicly reported yes or no what
happened whatever that first DYFS I well
why do the very Democrats who supported
Brennan now oppose Gina Haspel so what's
it what's change very confusing I'll
tell you what's changed Donald Trump is
now president and the Democrats he must
be stopped at all costs and he must be
denied the personnel to help him advance
his agenda you see it's really not a
tale of two confirmations it's a tale of
the two phases of the Democratic Party
one face says it supports a robust
national security and the other will do
whatever it takes to stop Trump and then
regain power and that's the angle